Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two. David P.
I want to warn you, I am going to play
for you now what I believe is the most
xenophobic voicemail I've ever received. It's
about me, the callers calling in about me. OK,
I'm not going to say anything else. Let's listen
to it. Then I will tell you why I'm highlighting
it, and I'll tell you a little more about it.
Speaker 5: You know what the trouble is with
America? Pacman is people like you from
the South America that are coming over the
border by millions disease infected pigs that
destroyed their own country. Now they want to
go and destroy my country instead of worrying
about us, Christians and the Republican Party.
Why don't you do something about stopping all
those sorry, son of a bitch is coming over
or coming up from South America just
like you? You know what? I want to see
every one of you have run out of this country.
You're the sorry son of a bitch is that have
ever been let into this country and you're really
an American. You would do something about it, but
I know where you're from. You've been cockroach.
Speaker 1: Why am I highlighting this? So,
of course, what this guy says is wrong. You
know, my my family didn't come over the border.
We came with a work visa for my dad and green
cards, and I'm a U.S. citizen. The reason I'm
highlighting this is that it seems lost on
this guy that I came over in the exact same.
We know who this guy is, OK, we know exactly who
this guy is. We're calling him Tulsa, Chris. He's
not actually from Tulsa. He's from a different
part of Oklahoma. We know exactly who this guy is.
We're calling him Tulsa, Chris. Just, you know,
that's what we're calling him, Tulsa, Chris. Based
on what we know is not Native American. And what
that means is that at some point, at some point,
someone in his family did the exact same thing
that my family did right? At some point, someone
in his ancestry came from a different country, and
then eventually you had the first generation of
his family that was born here. But the argument
he's making about me, I came here legally as
well is the exact same argument that at some
point could have been made against his family.
And when we talk about the immigration situation
in the U.S. and there's a lot to talk about, Doka
border overstayed visas, work visas, industries
that depend on documented and undocumented
workers, crime rates among documented immigrants,
undocumented immigrants and natural born U.S.
citizen. All of these are all issues we talk about
in their important issues. But it seems completely
missing for some people like Tulsa Chris, that
they were in the same position at some point in
time. And you would think that that would get them
to reexamine and say, what a shocker. Presumably,
he doesn't believe his family was cockroaches that
should have been sent somewhere else. Maybe it's
a racial thing. I don't know. Maybe European
versus South? I don't know. There's there's
probably more there, but the hypocrisy. And the
ignorance to that reality is part of what is very,
very disturbing about these folks. So there is
Tulsa, Chris with a message of me going back to
where I came from. I'm an American citizen,
so I don't think there's any changing that.
We're going to talk on the bonus show today about
the censure of Paul Gosar and some very strange
things he did after being censured for sharing
that video of AOC getting killed in anime format.
We're going to talk about a Republican backed
bill to do decriminalize marijuana federally. And
we will talk about another possibility for why gas
prices are going up. All of those stories and more
on today's bonus show. Sign up at GOign Packman
Unidentified: Gqom and we will.